good doctor carton 6,1 millions de
téléspectateurs on en a parlé un petit
peu la semaine dernière et c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens ici show pato
qui disait il nous rappelle maxime galy
mais c'est vrai est vraiment vous avez
énorme et c'est on a une tendresse pour
vous comme pour lui
oui il a débuté dans arthur et les
minimoys ayez quelques années des
serrures pour le côté chirurgien minutes
parce que pour le côté l'aja meken
d'accord en tout cas excuser moi parce
que vous devez vous nous donnerez vos
papiers qui vous êtes merci les chéris
pourquoi ça cartonne autant good doctor
est ce que ça te donne envie lara oui tu
vois ça un thème bien les séries où ça
avec les docteurs des trous j'étais
super fan de regarder je trouvais que ça
alors je sais pas si c'était fiable mais
en tout cas je trouve ça vachement bien
joué j'adorais son cynisme et ça c'est
ça ouais moi aussi j'adore alors je vous
dis par exemple
faut dire aussi que les médecins
arrivent souvent en tête des sondages
des métiers qui font le plus fantasmer
c'est vrai je alors est ce que c'est le
cabinet mme bah oui évidemment parce que
l'état détienne la vie et la mort entre
leurs mains donc forcément c'est un
métier qui nous fait fantasmer la blouse
blanche ne votera sur l'uniforme le des
canines dans l'âme on perd il est
médecin à la pâte uniforme lui de good
doctor who pertes lundi alors son
anniversaire sur mon document
mais merci alors non mais non mais juste
la dre au pair qu'est ce qu'il en dit le
good doctor alors je vais te dire à mon
avis n'a jamais regardé intello ils ne
regardent que les chaînes un fou mais
les séries médicales notamment urgence
une suscité de nombreuses vocations et à
de nombreux jours les médecins qui ont
d'abord regardé urgence qui était une
série phare gagne 1,14 et de nombreux
dangers qui a vraiment de donner envie à
des gamins de devenir médecin on en
parlera tout à l'heure ça le vrai savoir
pourquoi la série cartonne oui parce que
c'est très bien fait parce que l'acteur
est charismatique et parce que c'est une
usurpation total un mensonge éhonté
parce qu'on fait croire aux gens qu'on
met en avant l' autisme alors qu'on
utilise l'autisme pour faire de la
difficulté basé sur le mensonge mais
city dans le clip mais c'est pas pour ça
que ça a été dur mais promenade
aiguisons capitaine haddock ils n'ont
pas le rapport oui mais surtout la
première série médicale positive à mi
chemin entre ballades anatomy et docteur
house d'ailleurs le producteur qui
s'appelle david shore est connu pour
être le créateur de dr house et surtout
si ça fonctionne c'est grâce à l'acteur
principal qu'est si attachant et qui
s'appelle fraude y ait mort et en plus
elle est en plus de cela c'est quand
même le succès aux etats-unis la série
qui a réalisé 18 millions
téléspectateurs outre-atlantique
tradition oblige il ya très longtemps il
est médecin de nuit il était un immense
carton ça dd alors les vieux je vous
explique pourquoi ça marche enfants sam
et et le traditionnel assez riche et
c'est une tradition en france qu'on aime
beaucoup les séries sur les médecins et
ça fait très longtemps qu'on les regarde
en france et s'en fait pas la même chez
moi personnellement cette série là je
n'aime pas du tout voilà c'est mathieu
pourquoi ça marche en france dans la
vérité parce qu'ils font tout ce qu'on
sait pas ce qu'on sait pas faire tout
simplement les américains classés mère à
coup je perds ma tête c'est ton avis
c'est bien c'est génial musée c'est
original c'est bien joué c'est bien
tourner les acteurs sont assez beau
effectivement nous comptons faire une
série sur la médecine qu'on a un médecin
c'est dans le sous sol est où ses
médecins balam étudiants sharp d'accord
on sait pas faire là dessus on a fait
des erreurs dans mes films soleil c'est
la seule série où le gars et des
plagistes lourdement il
c'est le gars il la veille tu vois non
je veux installer transat à la 17
le lendemain il sort oui malheureusement
monsieur gilbert gagnes tu meurs c'est
ça la vega les gars y sont deux métiers
en deux sous le soleil faire le gars il
était boulanger
oui que c'est auxerre de baguette le
lendemain je suis devenu cascadeur mai
parmi ces deus là bas dans les scellés
française il n'y a pas de conduire
depuis un an c'est à dire les gars ils
sont maintenant je suis fasciné par yann
montent et descendent redescendre montée
te casser la gueule
un show à l'américaine je vais vous dire
pour l'instant on a fait 49 minutes
d'émission d'autres à clairvaux spine de
dons non non non alors essayer de faire
une bonne réflexion et une bonne
intervention passe mon tour isabelle et
non alors moi je me suis un mec mais je
me suis tapé toutes les séries et je
peux vous dire que benjamin tout à fait
raison good doctor est une merveilleuse
série parce que les personnages sont
attachants c'est pour ça qu'on a tâché
faut pas chercher plus loin et que c'est
très bien fait en revanche c'est pas
vrai les séries médicales c'est une
tradition européenne au départ et
notamment effectivement médecin de nuit
qui a été une série de réalité du coup
porté par une renault 5 août pour
désigner occasion de remettre sa nuit
les gars oui alors je m'en rappelle
maintenant je m'en rappelle y avait que
des mecs en voiture oui cas les médecins
de lui oui mais c'était une tare et les
gars c'était la seule série se réfère où
il filme et les trajets
oui bonjour vous à tout a bien du mal à
toulon oui voyons viendra donc chercher
dans 12 à 12 elle regardera d'écouté
c'est un prénom il des chances à tous
les quarts d'heure à nouveaux talents du
rire tout de suite fernand raynaud
exactement ça pierru devient médecin en
regardant sa keynote et sont sacrés